よろしくお願いします
で まあ今日からあの 今からあの
今日の講演会ですが 今日
私にこの心理カウンセリングですか
まあそういうテーマで話すように言われまして
まあなんとか頑張ってはみます
まずはあの  そういうテーマっていうのは
別に仏教のテーマではないんですね
そういう一般的にいろいろいろんなことに心の悩みを持っているということは
まあほとんど まあ現代病で
昔の人々にまあそれほど精神的な病気があったわけじゃないし
で 自然の中で生きてましたからね
まあそれなりにものを認めるという生活はありましたから
で 我々はものを認めないんですね
頭があまりにも良すぎて何も認めたくないんですね
台風が来たらそれを認めたくない
それをやめようとすること
地震が起きたら それをなんとかしてやめようとする
病気が出てくる それをやめようとする
それ 頭が良すぎか あまりにも悪すぎか
どっちか分かりませんだけどね
昔の人々はそんなことあまりなく
そのままに まあ台風が来たらもう全部終わりますよとね
で 寒冷になったら全部作物は消えちゃうよとかね
で そういうことを認めて生活したんですね
で 隣の国から戦争してきちゃったら
まあみんな死んじゃうよと
まあしょうがないと で
まあ自分にどうしようもない現象については
まあそのまま受け入れるということはね
昔の人々にありましたね
現代人にはそれないんですね
で なんか全部自分の手でコントロールできると思ってるんですね
でも何かコントロールしているかというとね
何一つもコントロールしていないんですね
こちらで何か抑えると
他のところで出てきちゃうんですね
モグラたたきのようなもんなんですね
ですから この現代人のその高慢さですかね
まあ俺たちが知ってるよというね
そんなけしからんな考え方さえ捨てればね
もう何の精神的な問題もないと思いますけど
ですから えーと まあ仏教には別に本来的なある話ではございません
で じゃあそれはともかく
で まあ仏教って何ですかというと
99%ぐらいかな  905%ぐらい経典にあるのは全部心の問題なんですね
心のこと喋ってるんですね
体のことを喋ってないんです
ですから まあ仏教はやっぱり心の教えなんですね
そういうテーマで言うならば
仏教は心の教えではないんですかと
それだったら我々の心の悩みとかなんとかなくす方法なんかあるんじゃないかなと聞いたら
まあそれだったらありますと
その点で聞くならば 仏教っていうのはこの心の科学なんですね
心理学というよりはサイエンスオブマインドなんですね
心の科学 心を科学する
いわゆる精神的な働きそのものは徹底的に科学する
で 科学するということは
普通の物理的な科学と同じく
徹底的に分析して そのお互いの関連性を理解して
自分の思うがままにするようにする
科学もそういうことでしょうに
新幹線があるわ 飛行機はあるわ
宇宙船があるわね いろんなコンピューターがあるわ
いろんなことあるでしょうに
世の中で不思議なものは
でまあ ですから それは科学の世界なんですね
科学の世界は この自然法則を科学して
自然法則の関連性 互いにどのように働きますか？それはきちんと理解して
それで人間にうまく 人間の幸福のためにうまく使うように工夫するんですね
いわゆる科学には実践的なもの
プラクティカルアスペクトというもの
確実にあるんです その点で見ると
お釈迦様が心を科学しているんですね
ですから サイコロジーと言ったっても
意味は辞書から引いてみると同じサイコアンドロジですから
ロジっていうのは学問であって
サイコっていうのは心ですからね
まあサイコロジーかもしれませんだけど
でもサイコロジーといったらまた違う学問分野になりますから
ですから私はサイエンスオブザマインドという単語を使いたいんですね
それは私が作っている言葉なんですけど
英語辞書を引いたってもないんですけど
で 心の科学あるいは心を科学する教え
まあそういうことで 皆様方は別にわざとあのカウンセリングとかね
まあ心理 何でしたっけ
心理療法ですか しん心理療法です
心理療法で  そういうテーマでいちいちもうなんでしょうかとね
まあきめ細かく探さなくたっても
お釈迦様の教えはどんなところ見ても心安らかになる
心を直す 心清らかになる方法はあるんですね
ですから この 1時間半ぐらいの 2時間ぐらいの話でまとまれるものではないんです
私にはまとまれませんだけどね
膨大な心の法則は書いてるんです
心理療法といえば やっぱり私の頭に浮かんだのは
なんか精神的に弱い えーと
いろいろ精神的な問題抱えている
んー 人々のためという考え方なんですね
それはどうか 正しかどうか分かりませんだけど
いわゆる精神科のお世話にならなくちゃいけない人々にどうしますか？というふうな話のような感じがしましたけど
で そうすると皆様には全然関係ない話になっちゃいますし
で かなり皆様大変話を聞いて
瞑想なさって まあそんな状態じゃないんです
で 大体この私の話を聞かなくたっても
まあ今結構瞑想なさってる方々は
もう今は十分自分で能力ついてると思います
他の人が何か悩んでいる人に会ったところで
すぐ自分の頭に来るはずなんで
その人にこうすればいいんだと
ですから ご自分でもうもうなんていうのは試してみてみてください
私は特別に指導していないんです
なんかあのカウンセラー養成みたいな感じで
でも瞑想をなさっている方々は自分でやってみてください
私 聞いた話は全部忘れて
誰かが何か悩みを持っている人に話してみてください
すぐ自分の頭にその人の心を慰めてあげる解決法がすぐ浮かぶはずなんです
ですから 皆様方はほとんどの方々はそういう今日勉強するとこはないかもしれません
皆様方は結局結局リーダーシップを取って
人々の心の問題を解決できるぐらいの能力をお持ちでいらっしゃると思います
で それからまあ 仏教は心の科学というならば
あるいは心を科学することを仏教だというならば
仏教にもそれなりに目的があるんですね
その目的はまず この話に入る前に理解してほしい
仏教の目的は あの わかりやすく言えば超越することなんですね
心の次元を破って それを超越することなんです
それははっきりとしているんです
で 我々 この教育の世界から
この神精神科のね あるいは心理学をやっている方々の立場から見れば
あの一般的な社会でうまく問題なく生きていられる状態が心の健康な状態だと考えているんですね
仏教はそう考えていないんです
例えば ヨーロッパの素晴らしい専門家のカウンセラーがいると
そこでここで私がいると
で ヨーロッパの素晴らしい専門家のカウンセラーが
人がうまく社会で生きていられるぐらいのことは指導するんですね
で 私は指導するならば
社会と何の関係なく 社会をいかに脱出できるかと
いわゆる心の次元をどうやって乗り越えるかということを教えたいんですね
それは私にとって仏教の世界は
その差がちゃんとしているんです
それをまず覚えておいてください
で 私はそれを一般的にこう考えちゃうんですね
で 普通 どんな人間でもノーマルな人間ですね
別に問題あるわけじゃないんです
で ちゃんと勉強して ちゃんと仕事があって
もうちゃんと結婚して
家族がいて まあうまく生きているんだと
問題はないんだと  それぐらいだったら誰でもノーマルな普通の人間だと言うんですね
そこで その中でたまに人々が現れちゃうんですね
学校に行きたくない 学校に行ってもなかなかみんなと仲良くすることはできない
何を勉強してもすぐ忘れちゃうとか
あるいはまるっきり勉強に興味がないとか
小さい時 そういう問題が出てくる
若くなってきたらどうも結婚したがらないとか
あるいは結婚はしたいんだけど
あの人見この人見 あの人見とか
まああまりにも欲が大きくて多すぎてなかなか決められませんとかね
それで仕事に行ったところで
面接でいつでももう自分が何て言いますか
もうダメになっちゃうんだと
人に会ったらもう喋れなくなっちゃうんだと
また 会社でなかなかみんなとうまくいかないんだと
それからお金入ったらすぐ使ってしまうんだと
明日のこと考えないんだと
で 借金しなくちゃいけないと
あるいはもう何か変なことをしてしなきゃ落ち着かないと
もう酒飲むか もうタバコに執着するか
何か依存症みたいなね
麻薬使うか何とかとかね
賭け事とかね あるいはパチンコでもいいんですね
毎日パチンコやっちゃうんだと
どうしてもやめられないんだと
借金でもしてパチンコやっちゃうとか
そういう問題があったりとかね
で また家族の場合はなかなか家族の中でうまくいかないとかね
そういうものは世の中でこの精神的な問題だと扱っているんですね
そこで そういう人々が一般の社会のレベルから以下なんですね
わかりやすいでしょ  普通の子供だったら学校に行って
仲良くよく遊んで まあ楽しく勉強する
それは普通であって それができない場合は
その子は何か心の問題があるというんですね
それで精神科の世界から
その子供たちやら人々を助けてあげて
普通の状態に上がる上がるようにしてあげるんです
それで仏教は何をやっているんですかというと
仏教はそんなことやらないんです
仏教で見ているのは 普通の人々はみんな精神的な問題ありと
この心理学立場から普通という人々が
仏教から見れば問題ありきということになっちゃうんです
あなた方は問題あるんだ
社会で堂々と頑張って
きちんと仕事をして きちんと家族を守って
ちゃんとやって もう死ぬ人々はみんな問題あると
あなた方はその問題を解決して
まあ普通に戻るべきですよと
ですから 仏教の立場から見れば
こういう風に図形描けられるんですね
で 普通の人々は 0点 まあ 0点でいるならば
精神的な問題がある人々はマイナス点にいるんです
仏教の心理療法では この 0点にいる人々はポジティブ点にプラス点に持っていこうとしているんですね
ということは どういうことでしょうか？やっぱり人間性を超えることをいつでも言っているんです
人間に戻ることではなくて
人間性を超えなさいと
人間に戻れということではないんです
そこはまず理解しておかないと問題なんです
それでいろんな言葉でお釈迦様はそういうことをおっしゃっているんですね
仏教の教え自体 まあ仏教の道
仏教の真理にある形容詞を使うんです
このアリアという形容詞を使うんですね
アリアアリアダンマ ダンマというのは法
仏教の真理にアリアサッチャと言うんです
勉強のために書いておきますけど
アリアダンマ ダンマは法
教え 仏教の真理にはアリアサッチャというんですね
仏教の実践方法にはアリアマッガというんです
マッガは道という意味なんですね
だから日本語訳すれば聖
聖なる法 聖法 聖なる真理
四聖諦という皆さんはご存知の言葉ですけど
聖道なんです この聖なるという聖という字使っているんです
まあ英語でノーベルという
まあ普通に我々訳しますけどね
いわゆる普通のレベルより大変優れた優れている超越しているレベルを目指しているんです
それからこの皆様 ブラフマンという言葉を聞いてるんですね
仏教の言葉を知っている方々はブラフマンという言葉を知っているんです
仏教ではブラフマンといったら
ちょっとまあ違う宗教という意味で取ってますけど
お釈迦様はそういう意味ではなくて
すごい簡単にブラフマナという言葉を使うんです
お釈迦様は自分の教えにもいつでもブラフマナという言葉を使うんですね
ブラフマンブラフマンというのは優れているという意味で使っているんですね
だから心を清らかにした人している人はブラフマナでブラフマンであると
ブラフマンというのはものすごい優れている人やという意味なんですね
そのブラフマナという言葉を仏教で使っているんです
それから仏教で言っている知識
普通の世界で言っている知識
普通の言葉で言う知恵
我々 我々一般的に使ってるんですね
まあ知識とか知恵とか
それまた仏教になると随分レベルが高いんです
仏教でパンニャーというプラクニャーという言葉がございまして
それは日本訳は知恵なんですけど
それで意味するのはものすごい超越した知恵なんですね
ですから プラクニャーの知恵の教えとも言うんです
超越した知恵 それから特別に分かりやすい言葉があるんです
このロークッタラという言葉
ロークッタラ このロークッタラという言葉は 2つの言葉で出て作っているんです
ローカという言葉と それに足してウッタラという言葉
ローカっていうのは世界という世間という意味なんですね
ウッタラっていうのは乗り越えているという意味なんです
ですから 仏教はまあ世間を乗り越えている道を教えているんだと
いわゆる世間の次元 世俗の次元を乗り越える道を教えているんだと
それからもう一つ言葉がありまして
それはウッタリマヌッサと読むんです
マヌッサっていうのは人間
ウッタリっていうのはもう飛び出したという乗り越えた次元を越えたと
あのスーパーマンという言葉は聞いたことありますね
映画ありますからね スーパーマンという映画が
まあスーパーマンの教えなんです
わかりやすく言えば どうすればスーパーマンになるかと
でも我々俗人が思っているスーパーマンじゃないんですね
あの空を飛ぶとかね 壁をやぶるとか
そういうスーパーマンじゃなくて
知恵 精神的に 人間の次元を飛び出しちゃう
乗り越える ですから ウッタリマヌッサ
仏教の知恵は全部ウッタリマヌッサの次元に入る知恵だと言っているんです
ですから 仏教のことはもう軽く見てはいけないとものすごい厳しく言ってるんです
私は知ってるぞとかああだこうだとか
そういうことを言ったら大変怒られます
仏教のこと ああ あれはこういうことやとものすごい軽々く言う人々はいるんです
仏教を軽く見ようと そんな軽く見られるものでもないんです
知ってるぞとかに 知ってるんだったら
あなた人間性を超えてるんですかと
また逆に聞きたくはなるんですね
ですから お釈迦様はお坊さんたちにもすごい厳しく戒めているんです
そこら辺では気をつけなさいと
もし人がお坊さんが修行して
そういう超越した何かことを得ても
それは全然一般の人には言わない
で 軽々く言うなと 大変レベル高いと
なんでそういうことを言いましたかというと
やっぱり仏教の教えがもう心心の心の科学かもしれませんけど
心を乗り越えることを教えているんです
科学と同じで 科学は自然のことを勉強するんだけど
自然法則を乗り越えることにチャレンジしているんですね
DNA の研究やら遺伝の研究と
どこまでいろんなことをなさっているでしょうに
宇宙にまで生きてるで
行ってるでしょうに 火星のことまでどう写真撮ったり
いろんなことをやったりしてるで
そういうのも科学の世界で自然を乗り越えているんですね
自然法則と同じく 心の世界で心の法則を乗り越えることをやってますから
私は仏教はサイエンスオブザマインドというのは適当な言葉だと思います
サイエンスであって でももう自然法則のサイエンスではなくて
サイエンスオブザマインド
心の科学 じゃあそれで問題は
我々今日扱おう 扱おうとしている
まだテーマに入ってないんだけどね
まだテーマの前の注意だけ
で ノーマルな人が 例えば 0.2ここにいると思ったら
普通のノーマル 我々みたいにノーマルな人間
社会にうまく生きていられるんだと
精神科に当たる人々が普通の社会でうまくいかないんですね
だからその方々はそこら辺でこのマイナスの次元にいるんですね
だから精神科がその人
こちら辺にいる人々に指導して
このレベルに世界 社会のレベルに持ち上がるんですね
仏教はここにいる人々にここら辺に行こうと言ってるんです
保守級の方向に だから心理学の人間性を上に持っていくんだけど
ここで止まるんです ここでストップ
仏教はここから始めて上に持っていくんです
そういうことで理解してほしいんです
ですから この精神的な弱い人の問題を扱うのは仏教の仕事じゃないんです
仏教は科学的な宗教だから
それはそれなりのお医者さんに聞いてみなさいと
あんたちょっと病気だから
病気治してきてくださいと
私は元気だと思ったらこっち来て下さい
そうすると私はあなた病気だから治してあげますよと
もっとさらに上に持っていきますと
わかりやすい例にしちゃうと
例えば人を人の足が折って歩けないと車椅子で行ってるんだと
言ったら お釈迦様はあんたね
お医者さんのところに行って骨を治してきて
歩けるようになってくださいと
言って  お医者さんのところに行って骨を治して
まあリハビリテーションをやって
リハビリやってもう歩けるようになったところで
またお釈迦様のところに来る
どうですか？今 元気で歩けますと言ったら
お釈迦様はい あんたは歩けないんだと
すごい呪いだと あんたは新幹線のように歩けなくちゃいけないんだと
歩くんだったら じゃあそれやってあげますと言って
それからのコーチするんです
いかにすれば猛烈な速さで歩けるんですかということ
そういう差なんですね
それぐらいで この仏教の世界の違うところ
心理の心理学の方で 仏教のところの違うところをご理解いただければ結構だと思います
そういうことで このなぜかというと
この この心の問題の場合はいろいろありますから
まあちょっとした人間関係とかね
社会の関係とかね そういう場合の問題だったら
誰にでもカウンセラーの方々に直せるかもしれませんだけど
あの生まれつき病気の人々いるんですね
体っていうのは肉体でできているんだから
脳細胞の異常あったり
体から分泌するいろいろホルモンがありますね
そういうホルモンの異常があったりとか
で 神経の伝達物質 いろいろ化学物質あるでしょう
そういうもののいろいろ異常あったりとかね
そういうのはお医者さんの仕事なんですね
それで精神的な病気というふうに我々思う人が
例えば生まれつき暗いと
その人は生まれつき暗いの特別な問題があるんじゃなくて
その人の神経システムの問題かもしれません
その人にいろいろいちいち指導したっても何の意味もないんです
その場合はちゃんとした医学の専門家ですか
ニューロロジストと英語で言うんですけど
神経の神経科の専門家に聞いてみて
それなりの治療を受けなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 仏教はもうなんだかんだみやるといって
余計なところまでは手を出さないんです
そこら辺はそういう人々の仕事
それもよく明確に理解してほしいんです
人がもし体の問題で精神的に弱いんだったら
それを体を治すのは医学の世界の仕事なんです
それはそちらに頼めばいいんです
ですから それはやらない
お坊さんたちにも禁じられているんですね
治療するのは それから一般的にいろいろありますね
昔からあったんです もう霊に取られたとかね
昔 科学は発展してなかったんだから
例えばいきなり人がフィストですか
このなんかこの体が震えたり
もうなんか目が目ん玉が上へ飛び出したり
いきなり意識がなくなったりとか
そういうふうにこのフィストみたいな
まあ普通の病気なんですけど
なったりした場合は これは悪霊に取られたんだと
と昔の人々と思ったんですね
そこで悪霊払いとかやっちゃうんです
そういうのは仏教では禁じられているんです
やめろと ですから祈祷ありますね
まあ皆様もご存知いていることで
人の悪 なんて言いますか
何払い まあそういう悪い悪霊払いをして
まあ大お祓いをしてなんとかしてあげるとかね
そういうのは初期仏教ではもう禁止ですね
やりたければそれなりのインチキなところに行ってやってくださいと認めてないんです
そんなことは ですから
祈祷とかしてなんか人を誤魔化すとかはないんです
で 禁じられているんですね
それ禁じられているのは
まあそういうわけで きちんとしたもう心の科学ですから
迷信はなしと たくさんポイントありますから
早く早く行きます じゃあまあまあ
これからまあそこそこテーマに入りましょう
で このテーマに入る前にこれだけ言っておきたいんです
こういうこの心の悩みなんかの場合は
経典の内容よりは仏教のストーリー
エピソード 物語を時々時話じゃないんだけど
たくさんあるんです その仏教に出てくるいろんなエピソードを読むと
お釈迦様はどのように心の悩んでいる人々を治してあげたかということはわかるんです
ですから そんなに仏教から見ればもう大した話じゃないんです
大変厳密に分析するべき大変な話じゃないんです
我々 この大事に考えている精神的な悩みというのは
なんか笑っているような感じで
じゃあ あるお母さんがいて
あの まあ一応家は貧しかったんだけどね
それでお嫁に行ったんです
お嫁に行ったところで
まあまあ貧しい家から来たんだから
なかなか立場がなかったんですね
で やっと彼女に子供が生まれたんです
子供が生まれたら まあ息子さんですね
それですごいもう立場ができちゃったんですね
もう跡継ぎができたんだから
それでやっと彼女が自分の幸せを掴まったんです
だからもう幸せいっぱいで
家でお嫁に行った家で
自分にはきちんとしたもう奥様として立場があって
大変みんなに尊敬されて
で やっと幸せをつかまったんです
それでその子はあの やっと走り回る
走り回って遊ぶ年になったら
あっちこっち走り回って
もう一生懸命遊んでいる年になったところで
急に病気になって死んじゃったんです
死んじゃったら そのお母さんどうなるでしょうかね
ものすごいショックでしょ
すごいショックで 自分が認めたくない
子供が死んだということを
私の息子は病気です と
必死になって子供を病気治そうとしているんです
そこで周りの人々はもう子供はもう亡くなったんだからもういい加減にしなさいと
で 怒って何言うんですか？私の子はもう病気ですと
私はこの子供を治してくれるお医者さん探しますと言って
あの子供の遺体を抱いて家を出るんですね
出て あっちこっちいろんなところに行くんです
行って いろんな医者のいろんなところに門を叩いて
どうかお願いします 私の子を治してくださいと言って
何ですか？と見たら あ
これ治せない もう治る
もうもう亡くなってるんだから帰ってくださいと
で そこに怒って何言うんですか？と
で 他のところに行く いろんなところに行くんだから
もうもうどこからも追い出される
そこでやる  頭の人々が
まあこれはもうこの人はすごい精神的に病んでるんだから
何とかしなくちゃと言って
まあお姉ちゃん もう すごいいいお医者さんがいるんですよ
このような病気だったら確実に治してくれるんだと教えてあげますよと言って
お釈迦様が住んでいるお寺の方へ道を教えたんですね
道を教えたら 彼女は大変喜んで
あ そういうお医者さんがいるんですかと
こういう病気だったら
あのせ あの先生しかないんだとみんなに言われたんだから
そしたらさっさとそこへ行ったんです
行くとお釈迦様はお坊さんたちもまとめて説法しているんです
それで彼女は走ってきて
あの先生 私の子供は病気ですから
なんとか先生治してくださいと言われた時
お釈迦様は何おっしゃったと思いますか？お釈迦様は何のことなく
ああそう はい わかりました
娘さん まあまあ 向こうのパーリ語で
我々でも今でもインド語で
インドの文化圏っていうのは
この人を呼ぶ時はお兄ちゃん
お姉ちゃん 弟と妹とか
あるいはお母さんとか娘さんとか
そういう兄弟の言葉で呼ぶんです
もうあまり名前を言わないんですね
お釈迦様も娘ぐらいの人は娘と呼ぶんです
うん 娘さん もうわかりました
治してあげます いきなりそれ言ったんです
あんたよく来てくださいましたよ
治してあげますよ あの一言葉であの人はどうなったかというと
まあずっと今までやった心のあの火事みたいになっていた
山火事みたいに悩んでいたんだけど
やっと先生に会ったと落ち着いたんです
ほっとほっとしたんですね
言ったら でもちょっと薬必要ですよ
まあ治療するんだから
ですから この マスタードなんですか？マスタード
からし からしの種っていうのはすごい小さいんですね
ちょっとからしの種 ちょっと持ってきてくださいと
インドっていうのはいくらでもからしあるんです
どこでもあるんです どんな庭でもあるんです
言ったらそれだけで十分ですか？と
からしの種だって 薬持ってきますよと言ったら
お母さんに でもお母さん
まあちょっとあります
問題は それは人が一人も死んでない家からもらってくださいと
わかりましたと言って
彼女はあの斎場の過去家を訪ねたんです
インドの町っていうのは
まあ皆様ご存知の通りに
もうかなり大きいでしょうに
ですから 人の家に行って
この私ね ちょっと薬必要ですよ
マスタードありますかと
からしあります ありますよと持ってきます
この家で人が亡くなったことはありますか？と言ったら
家っていうのはもうすごい代々の家の家だから
何言うんですか ところ
生きている人々よりは死んだ人の方が多いんですよと
ああ それいりません と次の家に行く
で 次の家に行く で  1 日中それで片っ端から家歩いたんです
それですぐと自分の子供も子供の遺体ですか
それも抱いてるんですね
それで疲れて疲れて疲れて
もうご飯も食べてないでしょうに
1 日歩いてるんだから
また前の日もかなり悩んだでしょうね
もう歩ける状態じゃないんです
それでももう子供に対するすごい愛情
執着だから それでも歩くんです
歩いては探す 歩いては探す
探して探して もう夜にもなってきます
それでも探しちゃう 探してももうどうしようもなく
また諦めたんです もう見つかりっこはないんだと
それでやっと死を認めたんですね
これは治らないんだと
死ぬというのと そこでそのまま遺体を墓場に捨てて
お寺にまた戻ったんですね
戻って 私を助けてくださいと
私を助けてください それでお釈迦様がはい
わかりましたと言って
世の中では生まれるものは全部消えるんだと
それに認めない人は随分苦しむんだと
そんなもんだよと すべて消えるんだと
捕まる必要は何もないんだと
心自由にしてくださいと
と説法と 彼女は出家して悟りましたけども
で そのストーリーで我々に見えるのは
お釈迦様はものすごく精神的に悩んで
この一般的なノーマル状態より狂った状態なんですね
その時はきちんと答えたことなんですね
そこでお釈迦様はちゃんと理解してたんですね
彼女の問題はなんですか？事実に直面したくない
事実から逃げようとしている
でも 事実に直面するしか方法はありません
事実を認めるということなんです
それで思い存分経験させたんです
徹底的に経験させちゃったんです
そのために ものすごい堂々と自信があって
あなたよく来てくださいましたと
直してあげますと ちょっとからしの種ちょっとだけ持ってきてください
それだけのことを言ったんです
そこでお釈迦様をカウンセラーとして見ると
釈尊が素晴らしくカウンセリングしたんですね
まずカウンセラーとして頼られるますよと頼られる
堂々たる人格ですか 持ってどーんと喋ったんですね
大丈夫ですよ 直りますよ
そんなことなんのこともないんで
ああ それぐらいですかと
というふうな この人の問題ですか
すごく自信あって受け止めたんです
ですから そこは覚えておいてください
私たちも人の心の悩み治そうとするならば
直してあげる人にとってはすごい
随分必要なのはものすごい
自信とその問題の理解能力なんですね
それから工夫 なんとか方法
それで次のストーリーなんですけど
だからもうストーリーでもう全部いけるんです
そういう話は で またお釈迦様の時代である箱入り娘がいて
ものすごい金持ちで 家から外へ出ることもない
大きなお城みたいなところで生活していたんです
で 大事に育てた娘で まあだからわがままに育てたでしょうと思いますけど
あまりにも贅沢させたいってわがまま全部聞いてあげても
お金は腐るほどあったんだから
全部聞いてあげる 欲しいものは何でもあげる
現代日本みたいに子供には苦労させませんと
で 育てたんですね で 女の子だから年頃になっちゃうんですね
年頃になっちゃうと 男性よりは随分異性についてはもう急に目が覚めちゃうんですね
そこで自分の家で召使いはいっぱいいましたから
ある若い男の子がもう大変格も低くて
まあ奴隷みたいなレベルで労働仕事をしているんですね
で この男の子を見たんですね
見た瞬間 もうもう恋に落ちてしまっちゃったんです
それはわがままな娘だから
その人と一応もういろいろ喋ったりする
でも その男の人にとっては喋ってもいけない
もう格の差が随分あるんです
自分がその家の召使いだから
で 怖くて怖くて 喋ったらもう話したら殺されるかもしれませんし
その女の子はそれぐらいも気がつかない
わがままだから なんであんたそんなに怖がりますか？とかね
私は私のことを嫌いですことある
女のことは知ってますけど
だけど私は言わなくたっても
で で まああなたのはあなたはすごい可愛いんだけど
でも私にも私の立場がありますよと
じゃあそれだったら二人でどこかへ駆け落ちすれば
お母さんがうるさいと
お父さんがうるさいと思うんだったらと平気で言うんですね
この女は知らないんですね
駆け落ちしたっても それから生活しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
人生のことまるっきりわかってないんだから
贅沢に育てられたんだから
あまりにもしつこく言うんだから
もうある日夜 この女の人がもう家を出て
あの男を引っ張って お前もうもう男くせになんでそんなに気が弱いんですかと
一緒に来いと引っ張っちゃって逃げちゃったんです
家を出て 家を出たら あの村に
あの町に あの国にいることさえもできないんです
捕まったら殺されますから
男の人 奴隷だから逃げることもできないし
で 他の国に逃げて もうどうやって生活しますかね
随分まず生活したんですね
ものすごい貧しい労働をやって生活していて
それで妊娠しましたし
妊娠したところでまたまたお母さんのことを思い出しちゃうんです
心配だから 不安だから
で 男の人にうちに帰りましょうと
もう子供もそろそろ産まなくちゃいけないし
うちに帰ろう ダメダメ
うちに帰っちゃったら殺されます
私は行けませんと ここで産みなさいと言っても
彼女はまた一人で家です
家出してうちに帰ろうと行くんですね
言ったらまあ男の人はやっぱり優しい人ですから
もう回らなくちゃいけないんだから
まあもうもう行ったところ
途中で森の中で彼女は子供を産むんです
だから贅沢な娘ですけど
子供とかは森の中で誰も手伝いなく
で 子供を産んだんだから
まあ今はうちに帰ったって意味がないでしょ
もう子供を だからね じゃあまた戻りましょうと戻るんです
そこでまた 2番目にまた妊娠したんです
また同じことで その日も逃げちゃったんです
お母さんのところに行きますと
逃げたら夜 まあ男の男性の方が
その女の人もかわいそうだからね
一人で行ったら危ないとまた探しに行ったんですね
探しに行ったら また森の真ん中でまた見つかる
見つかったらもう夜なんです
ものすごく雨が降る 猛烈に
このもう日本の雨とは違いますからね
それで彼女は腎臓を起こしちゃったんですね
そしたら男性の男性は
まあこれ大変だと 私はあなたに何とかして
この雨に濡れないように何か屋根を作ってあげますと言って
もう葉っぱとかなんとか取ろうといったところで
ヘビに噛まれて死んじゃうんです
で 彼女は男が来るまで待ってるんだけど
なかなか来ない それでものすごい雨の中で子供を産んだんです
寒くて震えるんだよ 体が
もうすごい血液出たり大変でしょうに
それで赤ちゃんはいるわ
もう 1歳ぐらいの子供がいるわ
その子供が病気になって死んじゃったらまた大変だ
それで自分のお腹の中に子供をして
なんか動物のような感じで
もう両手と両足でお腹の中で子供二人を守って
ずーっと徹夜朝まで待っていたんです
男に悪口言いながら あいつは逃げたかもしれませんとか何とかとか
朝起きて 想像してください
あの猛烈な雨で スクールですよ
止まりませんしね 夜 また森の真ん中
森の中 動物もいるし いろんなものが不穏なものがある
それでも箱入り娘さんでしょうし
で 朝起きてみたら旦那が死んでいるんですね
で ものすごいショックなんですね
しょうがない うちに帰ろうと思って帰って帰ろうというところで
川を渡らなくちゃいけない
川がものすごい洪水で
雨で渡れないんです そこで考えたのは
まず赤ちゃんを向こうに持っていくんだと言って
自分が赤ちゃんを抱っこして川を渡るんです
上の子にあなたはここで待ってくださいと言って
川を渡って向こう側に行って
まあそちらに葉っぱの上に子供を置いて
生まれたばっかしの赤ちゃんを置いてまた戻るんです
ものすごいこの水がもう強烈に流れている川に
川の真ん中ぐらいに入ったところで
この大きなワシみたいなね
イーグルですか そういう鳥がいるんだからね
鳥がそれ見たらもう狙おうとしてるんで
子供 ったらもうどうしようもないんです
戻れないんです 鳥の速さは
そこででっかい声で手を叩いて
ものすごいでっかい声
鳥をもう鳥 何て言いますか
おびき出そうと思って
もう叫んだんですね 手を叩いたりして
叫んじゃったら あのちっちゃな男の子が
あ お母さんに呼ばれてるんだと思って水に入ったんです
入ったらすぐ流されていっちゃった
で そっち見ると あの鳥が来て
子供捕まって持っていったんです
みんな死んじゃったの
1 日で 彼女は狂っちゃったんです
それでも自分の本能で家の方に行ったら
もう人々に聞いたんです
あの家はどうですか？どこにありますか？道とか聞いちゃったら
それだけは聞くなと あんまりもしっこを聞くんだから
なんであんたそんなにしっこ聞くんですよ
だってもうとにかくその家に行きたい
行ったら まあそのうちはもうないんだと
昨日の雨で雷が落ちて
その家の夫婦も兄弟がいて
その兄弟もみんないっぺんに死んじゃったんだと
だから一つその火葬 何て言いますか
場所 火葬場でみんないっぺんにまあ一緒に回しているところですよ
と言ったら 彼女はその瞬間で頭狂っちゃったんです
もう全部亡くなったんですね
で 彼女はもう行くところはないし
狂っちゃって 泣きながらあちこち走る
自分の着ていた服も全部落ちちゃったんです
それわからない そこでみんなに
子供たちに ガキたちに石を投げるわ
あっち行けこっち行けというわ
まあものすごいからかわれるわ
大変残念 残酷な状態なんです
そこでもう彼女がそういう状態の人を見て
このある日といて また仏教の信者さんたちが彼女にまあ
あなたはそういう服を着て
ここを曲がってここを行ったら
もうあなたには行くところがありますよと言ってお釈迦様のお寺に道を教えたんですね
行ったら裸で このお釈迦様のお寺に入っちゃうんです
入ると人々がもうあんた入るなと
病気だ もう狂ってるんだから入るなと言ったんです
入るなと言ったら まあ言ったらお坊さん
その言葉が聞こえたんですね
ただ なんのことはお釈迦様へ
彼女を通してくださいと
行ったら通るようにしたんです
そこでお釈迦様は一言葉言ったんですね
で 日本や日本風に日本語を文化的に言うなれば
あ おかえりなさいという言葉なんです
まあパーリ語では違う言葉なんですけどね
あ 娘さんよく来て まあどうそうどうすっていうふうな意味でね
娘と呼んでね 娘はお帰りなさい
あの おかえりなさいという言葉で
彼女に彼女はまた正気に戻ったんです
それで自分が裸でいることを曲がって
もう人から服を借りてもらって
まあもう説法を聞いて
それから出家して悟りましたけど
それには時間かかりましたけど
そこであれぐらい病気になった人はどうやって一言葉で治したんですか？そこは一番究極的な例
でも世の中に 例えば神戸の地震の時とか
みんないっぺんに瞬間に亡くなったっていうことは人間にはありますよ
それぐらい精神的なショックを受けても
一言葉で治るんです そこで分析してみてください
どういうことかと 彼女はまあまず世知らずというかね
世の中のことをまるっきり知らないわがまま育ちでしょうに
だからひどい目に遭ったんです
子供を育てるのは 子供に苦労させないとか
ああだこうだとか 親のわがままを好き勝手に育てると
子供はとことん苦労するんです
死ぬまで それも覚えておいてください
それは一つのポイントで
誰であろうが普通に育てなくちゃいけないんです
金持ちの息子であろうか
医者の息子であろうが
どうでもいいんです ただの人間だから
人間で生きてなくちゃいけないんだから
だから人間の社会ではそんなことは気にしない
学校に行ったら あなたはお医者さんの息子だからといって
すごいお坊ちゃまと呼ばないんです
この野郎 ああだこうだとか呼ぶんだから
だから社会に出たら誰でも平等ですから
そんな親が好き勝手に自分の子供だけ可愛がって贅沢させて
もうわがまま聞いてあげるということは
親ではなくて子供に不幸を作ってくれる鬼なんですね
まずそれを覚えておいてください
それから彼女にとってあった問題は
自分で独立することはまるっきりできないんですね
ずっと親に頼っていて
それからかわいそうに
もうあの男の人に頼っていて
とにかく人に頼ろうと人に頼ろうと
結局どうなったんですか？と
全部頼っていたものは消えちゃったんですね
ああ 誰に頼ればいいかと
もう頼るものは何もなくなっちゃったんです
だから最初から独立して生きる道を教えてくれなかったんです
独立しなさい それは教えてくれなかったんです
ですから 彼女には必要なのは独立できるぐらい強い精神でした
誰にも頼れません 私は私で生きていますというすごい精神力必要でしたが
それはまるっきり教えてくれなかったんですね
大人が それでお釈迦様もそれを
パッと理解したんですね
即瞬時に理解して何言ったんですか？おかえりなさい
あの おかえりなさいってことは何があるんですかね
自分の家に戻ったことでしょ
あれ あの言葉一言葉で
あ やっとやっと家に戻ったという
あ 安心だという あの実感が心に生まれたんですね
それも良くないんだけど
その場合はそれしか方法ないんです
彼女に必要なのは頼るところなんです
それは一言葉で お釈迦様の言葉の声がものすごい素晴らしい声でしたそうです
ものすごい響く あのすごい
もう低音というかね すごい声でしたそうです
あの声を聞くと 誰でも落ち着くみたいです
そういう声でお帰りなさいと言われたら
もうあれでじーんと心も静かになって落ち着いたんです
それからもう親のところに来たような感じで
それからお釈迦様からいろんな説法を聞いて
最後にお釈迦様はこう言ったんですね
この世の中で何も頼りもないんだと
誰も頼りにならないんだよ
両親も兄弟も旦那も子供も財産も
あなたの健康も 何一つもあなたの頼りにはならないんだと
全部捨てろ 自分にさえ自分さえ自分に頼ることをできませんと
自分自分さえ自分の頼りにならないんだ
それはすごい高度な心理なんです
それもう彼女がもう思い存分知ってるんです
あーわかりました 私はもう何にも頼れない心を作らなくちゃいけないと思って
ちょっと瞑想して 明かりがついてあったんで
自分の部屋で その明かりがもうずっと瞑想していたんだから
油が消えて明かりが消えちゃったんですね
ぱっぱっと2 3回大きい炎が出て消えちゃった
それを見ていて パッとその瞬間に悟り開いたんですね
そこで次のポイントなんですけど
自分さえ自分を頼りにならないということは
この精神的な弱い人々の場合
よくわかるでしょうに
私たちに私たちの心さえ信じることをできないんです
自分の心を信じることできれば問題ないでしょうに
例えば 何かちょっとした予想しなかった出来事に遭ったら
人はものすごいショックを受けるでしょうに
ショック受けて自信なくなって
家も出ることもできなくて
家に閉じこもっちゃっている人々いるでしょうに
あれどういうことかというと
ちょっとしたショックを受けちゃった途端
ちょっと心に何かあった途端
自分の心さえ自分の頼りにならないんです
我々はしっかりしなさいよと言ったっても
本人の心さえ本人を助けてくれない
でも ヨーロッパ的な心理学ではそれを認めない
それはやっぱり自分の精神は素晴らしいんだとかあれとかって言うんだけど
私は仏教でそう言わない
あんなもの頼りにならないんだと
自分の心でさえ何かあったらもうひどい目に遭いますから
ちょっと心に傷ついちゃったらもう終わりなんです
人生は 体に傷ついちゃったら
ちょっとバンバンなんていうか
絆創バンド貼っちゃえばそれで治りますけど
バンドエイドですか 10円ぐらいで治りますけど
心にちょっと傷ついちゃったらもう全然治らない
だから頼るなと で その場合でも
一般の人よりレベル低い精神的な病気の人は
お釈迦様は瞬時に直してあげて
その瞬間にその人は高度なレベルのところまで持ち上げてあげたんですね
で そのストーリーで次のストーリー
で そのストーリーの中で勉強するものたくさんあるでしょ
例えば親の育ち方 なぜ例えば現代日本でいっぱい問題があるかというと
親が悪いんです 小学生も殺人起こしちゃいますから
暴行やらいろんなもう恐ろしいことをするんじゃないんですかね
別に日本の社会っていうのは悪い社会じゃないし
随分平和な社会で お互いにすごく気をつけて
ものすごい行儀よくいる社会でしょうに
こんなに立派な社会なのに
いきなり高校生が何かやったとか
今高校生の私が前来た時は高校生ぐらいの人々
大学生が悪いことしていたんだけど
それからそれ高校生になっちゃい
それから中学生になっちゃって
今中学生とかね 小学生とかとんでもないことをやったりする時代になっていたんですから
だから こういう社会で育てられて
こんなにね もうしっかりともうなんだかんだでももう整理されている
このような平和な豊かな社会で育てられているのに問題あるということは
やっぱり育ち方でしょうと思いますよ
学校と両親の問題だと思います
まず子供の場合は 大人の場合はまあ社会と会社ですね
問題作っちゃう だから下手な連中結婚したっても
いい家族はできないでしょうに
育ちが悪い男が育ちが悪い女が一緒になったらもう倍育ちが悪いですからね
それで家庭の中で問題が現れるんですね
だから 今言ったストーリーでは
あの 一応名前を覚えてください
前のあの子供が亡くなったお母さんの名前はキサーゴートに
みんな悟っていた悟った方々なんです
キサーゴートに ゴートミーという名前だから
かなり格が高い方だと思います
お釈迦様の家の名前もゴートミーだからゴートマだから同じ姓名なんです
で これは子供が亡くなったお母さんの名前
すべて亡くなったわがままの人の名前はパターチャー
これはあだ名なんですね
パターチャー 我々にはこの 2番目の女性のストーリーがすごく関係あるんです
現代人にはね だから例えば日本の社会だといつ地震が起こるかわかりませんし
だからもうほんの 2 3 秒で全部死んでしまうとかね
例えば火事があるし 火事があっちゃったら
全財産瞬時に消えてしまうでしょうに
ですから その時どういう精神でいればいいんですかと
という答えなんですね
何も頼る必要はないんだと
全部消えるんだから まあいいんじゃないかと
それで だから私の今日の話を始める時も私は言ったでしょう
現代人のわがままというか
頭の悪さですね 何も認めたくない
それはあまりにもひどいんです
自然を認めたくないということは
地震があってもうおじいさんもおばあさんもお母さんもみんな死んじゃった
子供も死んじゃったんじゃ
認めなさい そんなことは別に不思議でもなんでもないんだから
止められますかね そういうことは止められませんだから
人間止めると思ってるんですね
それはえらい間違いなんです
それで神様まで恨んじゃうんですね
助けてくれなかったと
何も頼りにならないよと
このパターチャーさんのストーリーで教えてくれるんです
ですから もう自然認めたくない
自然法則を認めたくないというのはあんまりにもひどいんです
自然 ごく普通に まあ世の中には起こる出来事ですよと
もう一つ例を言いますけど
例えばもう医者ががんになったら言ってくれないんですね
すごいひどいんです ああいうことは
文化自体ひどいんですね
言ってはいかんと なんで言ってわけありませんですかね
言わなかったんだから
がん治るんだったら言わないのは正しいでしょうね
言ったって言わなくたって
もうがんはがんだから
その本人に残りの人生 1ヶ月間であろうか
1年であろうか  2週間であろうか
計画を立てて生きていられるように
ちゃんと強い精神 死ぬ瞬間まででも作ってあげなくちゃいけないでしょうに
言うべきなんです で いえ
違いますよと言っちゃうんですね
そこで面倒を見る人々は
ずっと死ぬまで嘘をつく通らなくちゃいけないんですね
あれ いいと思いますかね？お母さんに嘘を言っているとかね
お父さんに嘘を言って騙されて死んだとかね
そういうのはよくないんです
だから がんです 言った途端
みんなあれ 何ですか？と
なんで私はがんになりましたか？とすぐ思っちゃうんですね
別に私はというのは特別な偉い人じゃないんだから
誰々誰とも同じ普通の筋肉を持ってるんだから
がんであろうが何であろうが
もうもうかかる病気はかかりますから
そんなものは放っておけばいいでしょうに
それなりに治療あるならば治療を受ける
治療ないんだというならば
まあそのまま楽しく明るく人生残り日にちを計算して
私には 3ヶ月間しかないんだと
したら 90 日間でしょうに
1 日 1 日 もう 1 日 今日はこれこれと今日はこれこれやるぞとかね
いかに明るく生きていられるかというと
その自然を認めないことは一番大きな問題なんですもん
それはパターチャラのケース
それから 2つ 女性のケース出ましたから
なんか女性サービスと思うかもしれませんだけど
じゃあ 3番目は男性のストーリーを言います
で ある男がいて ものすごい
まあ男性だからすごい勉強できて頭がいいんです
そこでまあそれもまあそれなりの大変
あの王様の第 1 番目のカウンセラーの息子の息子なんですね
ですから すごい立場が強いんです
大臣のクラスでいえば
第 1 番目の大臣みたいなもの
大臣より立場が上なんです
王様の顧問だから こうした方がいい
どうでしょう こうした方がいいんじゃないかとアドバイスする人だから
その人の息子なんですね
生まれたすぐもう まあ生まれて
まあまたいろいろ不思議なストーリーいっぱいあります
全部省きますが それでまあ学校に行かせる
インドの学校っていうのは住み込みで勉強しなくちゃいけない
で 一旦行ったら まあ大体12歳で行っちゃったら
まあ大体 30歳ぐらいまで勉強しちゃうんですね
そこでそこで勉強していると
あまりにも勉強できる
いつでも優等生で もう何一つももう間違いとか弱いところは何もない
あんまりにも勉強できるんだから
どうしても先生の方がもうなんとなく
なんて言いますか 可愛くなっちゃうんで
先生にはもうあの子はもうすごい出来た弟子だなと
そうなっちゃうんです
そこで他の生徒たちに
なんて言いますか 生徒たちの嫉妬を買ってしまったんですね
他の生徒たちも先生に可愛がってほしいんだけど
なかなか先生はまあこいつらあまりろくに勉強しないということで
もうあまり親切じゃないんですね
だからいつでも先生とこの人は仲良くしているんですね
それで嫉妬を買われて
それでその他の弟子 生徒たちがぐるってなんかお互いにいろいろ話し合って
あの その人はこの先生の奥さんとできているんだと
ストーリー作っちゃったんです
それはインドではもうものすごい恐ろしい罪だと思うんですね
先生は神様みたいに尊敬するんだから
奥様も同じなんです ですから
見たら先生の奥様から見ても本当に出来た息子だから
それ可愛いんですよ 本当にできてるんだから
ものすごい可愛いんです
だから奥様ともかなり親しかったと思いますし
それは書いてないんだけど
ストーリーではね それで先生の耳にあの考え方を入れちゃった
入れられたところで なかなか奥さんともこの子は親しいし
やっぱりそうだろうと思ったんですね
思ったら まあこの人を殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
これ許すわけにいきません
そしたら私が殺ったら自分が犯罪者になっちゃうし
生徒たちに頼んで殺しちゃったらみんな捕まれるし
じゃあなんとか工夫しますと思って
勉強終わるまで待って
勉強終わったら先生 まあ先生に終わったところで礼をして
あの なんて言いますか
学費払うんです 全部終わったら言ったら
あなたからは学費は要りませんと
あなたはその代わりに一つのこのお供え
まあヒンドゥー教だから儀式
儀礼いろいろありますが
その儀礼 儀式にあなたやってくださいと
どういう儀式と何でもやってあげます
先生のためならと言うんですね
それだったら この私は神様に人の指をね
全部差し上げると 約束あったんだから
それあんたは若いんだからやってください
でも 一人の人から 1本の指しか取ってはいけないんだと
言ったら その人はもう勉強バカであまり勉強できすぎるっていうのはまた良くないんです
皆さんも知ってるでしょうに
まあまあまあ ただ何も世の中知らない
ただ本読んで丸暗記するだけの連中がもう人を殺したりしたでしょうに
あれは頭いいわけじゃなくて
あんまりこのまあものすごい心が狭いしね
まあそれは置いといて
まあ勉強ばっかしだから勉強バカなんですね
とにかくそこで先生が言うことは何でも正しい
で わかりましたと言って
この人はもう武器を持ってもう森に入ったんで
人殺しに いて それまた若いし
体力はあるし ものすごいもう恐ろしい人なんです
やることやるんだから
とにかくみるみる人を捕まって殺す
殺して指を取る 指を取って指をあっちこっち置いておくんだけど
それを動物に食べられたりする
それで数がわからなくなっちゃったんですね
あ これでもうやりきれないんだと思って
それから彼が人を殺して指を切って
首輪を作って それに繋げておくんです
で 自分の首にかけてるんです
全部人の指 自分殺した
全部拾わなくちゃいけない
それで人を殺すは殺すはキリがないでしょうに
もう国ごとにみんな怖くなったんです
恐ろしい鬼みたいな大泥棒ができたんだと
そこで捕まろうと捕まろうと
誰が行っても捕まれません
あんまりにも鋭くて 誰が行ったっても殺される
もうどうしようもない
で 最終的には王様がもうどうしようもなくて
軍隊全部動かして自分で出て行かなくちゃいけない状態になっちゃったんです
普通のグループは行かないんです
それで王様さえ怖かったんだ
あいつはもう森の中でゲリラ戦争をやってるんだから
まあ自分は軍隊で行ったってもやられるんでしょうと
ものすごい怖くなったんです
そこで王様が立ち上がるということで
お母さんが今度は私の息子は捕まりますと
ですから 自分が森に行って逃げよ
逃げ 逃げなさいと言ってあげましょうとお母さんが思ったんですね
やっぱりお母さんにとってはもう自分の息子だからね
お母さん ものすごい朝早く起きて
お父さんに言わないで
この息子いる森に入るようにしてるんです
で その人はもう全部 999本取ってるんですもん
あと一本で それで自分のこの苦しい人生終わって
普通の人間に戻られると思っているんです
8本まとめて先生にあげたところで
まあ親のところに戻られるんだと思っていたんだから
今日は誰が来ても殺すんだと
彼も疲れたんですね 今日は誰が来ても殺すんだと
何の関係もなく で そこでその日でお釈迦様もそのことを考えて
あ 今日はあいつは自分の母親もわからなくて殺すんだと
母親を殺したらもう治りはもう終わりと
その罪を起こしちゃったら
もう救うことはできないんですね
ですから 私はその前にやらなくちゃいけないと思って
お釈迦様は森に出るんですね
お釈迦は森に出たところで
お釈迦様はわざとその人いるところで歩いているんです
まあどうせお釈迦様だからゆっくりゆっくり歩くんですね
行ったらこの人があ やっと今日はよかった
走らなくてはよかった
もうもうなんて言いますか
まあ行者だからね そいつらは走りませんし
まあ何のことなく捕まえるんだと
言って追っかけていくんですね
追っかけていくんだけど
不思議なこと 捕まりません
見るたびには お釈迦様はゆっくり走るように見られるんです
でもかなり早く歩いているんです
その人は走っていくんだけど
捕まりません それは私も皆さんに歩く瞑想すると教えていますね
上半身は動かすなと 上半身を動かさないで歩くとかなり早く歩けるんです
それでなんかゆっくり歩いているように見えるんです
下手な人は体ばっかり動かしてるんですね
肩こうやって広々動かしたらよく歩いてないんです
でもお釈迦様はちょっとした神通力も使ってましたから
この一方の距離にかなりの距離をつかめるように縮んで縮んで歩いてるみたいに
それはお釈迦様ができるんだけど
普通の人はできませんだけど
で 彼がお釈迦様を追っていって捕まらないとこう言ったんです
シャモンシャモンというのは
いわゆる出家者の呼ぶことをシャモン
止まりなさい 止まれと
止まれとお釈迦様は 君止まりなさいよ
私は止まってるんだからと言ったんです
いきなりその人 何言うんですか？と驚いちゃったんです
君 止まりなさいよ 私はもうすでに止まってるよと言われた瞬間で
そしたら出家者は嘘を言うわけじゃないし
そしたらあんた何言うんですかね？私は止まってるのに
あんた走ってるでしょうにとお釈迦様に言うんです
このシャモン あなたが走ってるでしょうに
走ってるあなたが止まってるというし
止まってる私が走ってるというし
何者かと それはと言ったら
なんのことなく お釈迦様が君がもういろんな悪いことをいろんなことをやったりしてね
走ってるでしょうに 私はすべてやめているんだと
すべての行動を停止しているんだと
だから止まってるんだと
言ったら 自分の本当の心をパッとまた戻したんです
戻して すぐその瞬間で
あ これを聞いて理解しなくちゃいけないんだと思って
教えてくださいと で 教えてもらって
その場でその人が出家するんです
ほんの短い時間の出来事なんです
出家して お釈迦様はじゃあ私のところに帰りましょうと
朝 お釈迦様は朝出かけたんです
お寺に戻ったんです もう悟ってるんです
説法を聞いて瞬時に で
朝もうお釈迦様 王様が随分軍隊をまとめて準備して
いろんな鎧ああだこうだとかかけて
でも自分が出かけるのは心配なんです
自分も殺される可能性あるんだと
向こうはゲリラ戦争だから
いて とにかくもうちょっとからくりしたんです
私はとにかくお釈迦様に挨拶しますと
ブッダに もし私が殺されるようになるならば
お釈迦様はどうせ私のことを心配するんだから
あなたは行くなと言うだろうと
行くなとおっしゃったら
私はお釈迦様に行くなと言われたんだから行きませんよと止まりますと
そうすると自分のメンツも立てれるし
そういうちょっとした考え方もあって
お釈迦様に朝会ったんですね
朝会ったらお釈迦様はなんであんた今日変でしょう？なんか戦争でもやるつもりですか？と
何か隣の国でも戦争に出ているんですか？と聞いたんです
ったら まあ隣の国だったらわかりますけど
私の国の中で大泥棒が出ているんだと
ものすごいもう殺人詐欺切りがない
言われたらもう あ そう
じゃああなたに聞くんだけど
もしあなたがその大泥棒が出家して
心を清らかにして 蟻一匹も殺さない心を作っているならば
あんたどうしますか？と言ったら
まあそれだったら私もその人に頭下げて礼をして
もう守ってあげますと
それぐらい治ってるならばと言ったら
お釈迦様は王様の手を捕まったんです
あまりお釈迦様しないことなんです
王様の手を捕まって まあよく恐ろしいですけれどけど
あんたね この私の隣のこの比丘がその人ですよと
なぜ手を捕まったんです？そうでないと逃げちゃうんです
怖くて それぐらい怖い人でしたから
王様が逃げちゃったらもう終わりでしょうね
王としては だからお釈迦様は先にその人を捕まえていたんです
だからお釈迦様の人の心を読むことと
他人のことを心配することのこの大きさを考えてください
王様の立場を守ってほしいし
この人も守ってほしい
それは王が守ってくれなきゃ
王が命令しなきゃダメですからね
殺人者だから そしたら王様を見たら
本当はびっくりしてものすごい怖くなったみたいだけど
お釈迦様に捕まれてるんだから
また安全にして その場でその人に礼をして
じゃあこれからしっかりと修行してください
私はあなたのことを守ってあげますと
やっぱりそこで手帰っちゃったんです
で そのストーリーで現代心理学的に分析すると
その人の頭狂ったんですね
あれは学問の馬鹿なんですね
勉強バカで世の中見えないんですね
ただ一つだけてことんやるということは
決して洒落になるなることじゃないんです
もう結構日本で見えるんで
その現象も 何か一つに凝ったらそればっかりで周りは何も見えません
それで人生は完璧な人格はできてこないんです
今 医学の世界にしたっても
心臓の外科は心臓のことしか知らない
神経科は神経のことしか知らないとか
あまりにも細分化されちゃって
もう頭が悪いだけなの
結果としては それで病気になって病院に行ったら
もう病気治してくれるところじゃなくて殺されてくれるんですね
ですから それもこのあまりにもこの一つだけ深く深く深くやるだけでやって
この他のものとあるこの関係やら
それはやってないんですね
だから ただ単に何一つ勉強するということは
それだけではダメなんです
例えば東大に入ろうと思って
むちゃくちゃ丸暗記するんだとかね
それで頭いい人にはならないんです
丸暗記できるかもしれませんだけど
特に勉強よくできるという日本で見られる現象っていうのは
ものすごい弱いという現象で
僕に見えるんですね なぜかというと
言うことをそのままに丸呑みする
そのまま鵜呑みにする
もうちょっと先生に当たってみようとかね
ちょっと比べてみようとかね
ちょっと反対してみようとか
自分でも比較してみようとかね
それはしない そうすると先生から見れば随分いい生徒なんですね
よく勉強してくれる よく宿題やってくれる
あれで本人の意思はどう？どこに飛んじゃうんでしょうかね
ですから それをその現象も現代社会にはそのままあるんです
この勉強 いわゆる一つだけ徹底的にやって
それで頭が悪くなると
社会という大きなシステムの中で
我々は歯車のように仕事をするんだけど
歯車には他のものの関係なければ意味がないでしょうに
勝手に回ったって 自分だけ一人勝手に
だから このあまりにも細分化されているこの専門的な世界っていうのは良くないんです
例えば会社でものすごい仕事を上手な人が家に入ったらもう最悪でしょうね
何もできない 会社ですごい成功して仕事をする人は退職
退社 退職したらもうそれっきり
どうやって生きていればわからないでしょうに
そういうことなんですね
ですから 一人自分だけ一人勝手に回って回って回って回るときはいいんだけど
それはやっぱり社会という大きな絵の中の一部ですから
それ一つだけもう果てになっちゃったら絵にならないでしょうに
ですから 我々はそれも気をつけてほしいんですね
何を勉強したっても 医学でもいいし
数学でも何学でもいいんだけど
それは社会という大きな絵の中のほんの一部ですよと
舞台の演技と同じなんです
舞台で何か演技やってると
小さな細かいことをやる人々もいるでしょうに
その人はもう一番前に出て
ものすごいことをやったりすると
もうならない ドラマにならないでしょうに
例えば音楽を歌う時でも
バックコーラスとかあるでしょうに
私はたまに聞いている時は
バックコーラスやってる人々は
メインに歌う人よりも声がうまい時ものすごくあるんです
みんなプロたちだから
バックコーラスやってるのは
まあ声楽者たちだから
前に出て歌うのは下手な人ばっかりです
アイドルアイドルアイドルさんばっかりだから
声は悪いし聞いていられないし
もう でもバックコーラスの方がすっごいものすごい
もう音楽的にきちんと歌ってるんです
でもバックコーラスだからバックグラウンドで歌うんです
その人は自分歌上手だからとでっかい声で歌ったらどうなるんですかね
歌にならないでしょうに
ですから そこでちゃんとした
この何といいますか ディシプリン
訓練というものがあるんです
精神的に それぞれ楽器の音の高さやら強さやら
それをちゃんとコントロールして
バックコーラスやってる人々
それなりにきちんとゆっくりそのレベルを上げたり下げたりして歌うと
美しい歌というものは出来上がっちゃうんです
ですから 結果っていうのは
みんなの部分をしてあげたとき出るものであって
自分だけ一人で勝手に動く回るんじゃないんです
ですから それを理解した上の勉強なんですね
それを理解した上の仕事なんですね
だから今の経済状態そうなったんだからね
金融関係とかね 自分だけのことを考えて
金儲かることだけ考えてやったところで
もう破産してしまっちゃいますから
そうじゃなくて 社会というものがあって
世界というものがあって成り立っているんだと理解すれば問題ないと思いますよ
とにかくこのストーリーに戻りますが
そのストーリー その人はそういう知識的な
まあ知識はある 頭はいい
でもすごい狭い お釈迦様はこの狭さを教えてあげたんですね
あなたは狭いんだと でもそれを人はあの頭いいんだから
きちんと合理的に すごいなんか大胆な
知識的に言うと聞いてくれるんです
勉強した癖があるんだから
そこでお釈迦様はそれを取って
この人にはものすごい解読できない質問を出しちゃったら
この人すぐあれ？あれ何ですか？と興味があるんだから
ですからお釈迦様は私は止まっている
あなたは走っていると
言った途端 これすごい
もう問題なんですね その人はもう考えなくちゃいけない
それで彼がまた心を開いて教えてくださいということになったんです
で お釈迦様は生きるということは生命を愛することであって
生命を破壊することじゃないんだと
生命を愛するために 生命を助けるために勉強するんだってということはね
武器を持たない持たぬことは勉強であって
武器を持つ持つことじゃないという淵源と説法したんです
それでやっと彼が生き方を見つかって
もう阿羅漢になって悟りましたけどね
だから そういうストーリーの中でも
お釈迦様のこの診療方法ですか
やっぱりその人の性格に合う方法で
その人を治してあげたんですね
そういうストーリーはもうあるわあるわあるわ
ものすごいたくさんあるんです
もう時間なくなりましたけどね
また30分しか30分ありますけど
で そういう風に一つ一つストーリーを解読すると
なんとかわかるようにはなるだろうと思います
えーと 今日は一日では終わらないかもしれませんだけど
来月のします 残りは えーと
あまりにもありすぎてまとめられませんね
私は 2つのことを考えているんですね
一応テーマとしては 一つはこの心の問題って何ですか？それはどうすればいいかということと
もう一つはこの このカウンセラーですか
皆さん別に精神的に病気じゃないんだから
皆様方から必要なのは
やっぱり悩んでいる人を助けてあげることなんですね
ですから 私はカウンセラーとしての生き方
やり方を教えた方がもっといいんじゃないかなと思います
両方やらなくちゃいけないし
まあ両方ともかなり膨大な世界なんですね
ですから まあとにかくそれ一部として
心の問題ということをちょっと考えてみましょう
なぜ心が問題を作るかということ
で まず覚えてほしいのは
我々は心で生きている
それはもう確固たる事実なんです
ご飯できてるわけじゃないんです
心で生きている で 心がなければ手を上げることをさえできない
喋ることもできない まぶたを閉じることもできない
この体の行動すべてが心がやっているんです
体っていうのはただの物体です
体の中に別になんもあるわけじゃないんです
体っていうのはただの肉体で塊で物体で
心を抜いちゃったら腐ってしまっちゃうんです
なんのことなく 体から心を抜いちゃったら
皆様もなんのことなく平気でそれ燃やしてしまうんです
残った抜け殻を ですから
大事なのは心なんですね
手を挙げることさえ 心で手を挙げている
手を下げることも心で手を下げている
足を動かす時でも心で足を動かしている
そういうことで そういう心が
なんで病気になるか この病気という
病気ということは次元 2つありますね
まあ普通の一般的に 我々は普通の社会人として動かない時は病気というし
仏教だったら調子出てないんだからといって病気だという
両方病気は病気なんですけど
まあいろんなことを考えられるんですね
あの あまりまとめないんだけど
まあその適当に思い浮かぶたびに言います
1番目に この自害意識
自我意識という問題 私たちに自分という意識があるんですね
私という それは普通にアイデンティティとも言うんですね
自分のアイデンティティ
私がいるということ 私は田中さん
私は田中です もう何々もですとかね
森田ですとあそこだとかはあるんですね
その世の中のことを聞くと
まあきちんとしたアイデンティティあった方がいいんだと
自分ということはしっかりしろというふうにも言われるんです
私はこういうことをやりたいとしっかり知りなさいと
いわゆる自我意識をしっかりしなさいということも言われています
そうするとあなたには問題ないんだと
でも 私たちはもうちょっと言いたいんですね
この自我意識がしっかりするのはいいんだけど
そこでまた自我 自我意識があるんだから問題作る人もいるんですね
あまりもそれはもう他の言葉で言えば
あまりもエゴが強くて
ですから まあ自我意識はいいんだけど
エゴはよくないんだと
と覚えておいた方がいいんじゃないですかね
エゴイストではよくないんだと
それでこの自分というものはしっかりして
まあ私はそういうそういう能力ある人であって
私はこういうこういうものはやりたいんだと
こういうこういう人生をしたいんだと
こういう仕事をしたいんだと
こういうことを勉強したいんだと
こういうふうな生き方をしたいんだと
しっかりと自分のプログラムですか
人生のプログラムを組み立てる人が問題ないんですね
自分のプログラムを組み立てて
それのように生きていられると
それはいわゆるちゃんとした自我意識
自己意識というか アイデンティティと言えますね
そこで問題になるのはエゴなんですね
同じ言葉なんですけど
私はこういうもので 私にはこういうこういう才能があって
私はまあこのような人間になりますよとまた決めちゃうと
エゴが出てくる エゴが出てきちゃったら問題なんですね
だから これすごい なんかもう鋭い刃物を使ってるようなことなんですね
自我意識なくてはならないし
あっては危ないということなんですね
それは普通の心理学では言わないことで
仏教ではだいたいそういう立場なんですね
ちゃんとした自我意識がなくてもならないし
あったら危ないものだと覚えておかなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 私は例えば会社を作りたいと
こういう風な感じの会社を作りたいとしっかり思って
その方向で行動すれば
それは別に何の問題もないんですが
それちょっとエゴが入って
私はこういう風な会社を作りたいんだからと言っても
何度かんでもやるようになっちゃったら
どんなもんになるかわからないんですね
だからあまりにも強いエゴみたいになったところで
その人はどうなるかというと
柔軟性を失っちゃう やりたいことだけにしかだけしか見えなくなっちゃうんですね
柔軟性を失う もう一つ
例えば自分が若い人が東大に入りたいと思ったと
東大に入りたいと思ったところは別に問題はない
それなりにきちんと勉強もすると
それだったら問題ない
でも もうちょっと柔軟性もあってほしい
私は入るよそうではなくて
入ってやるぞと思っちゃったら問題になるんです
そうじゃなくて 東大に入るか入れないかということは
またいろんな要素が組み合わせたところの結果であって
自分だけの自我エゴで通るものじゃないんだとも理解してほしいんですね
なぜならば 東大にしてもそんな大きいところじゃないんだからね
もうもう何万人も学生いるわけにはいきませんし
もしその年で入学試験を受けた人々はもうみんなすごい高い点数を取ったならば
やっぱり切られちゃうんですよね
ですから 必ずも勉強したんだから入るんだと思ってしまえば
ものすごい挫折感で悩まなくちゃいけないんですね
なんで私が受験した年に限って
みんなもうすごい上手でしたとか
もう怒りまで出てきちゃうんですね
なんで私は不幸でしたとかね
すごい問題が出てくるんですね
ですから まあいくらか自分の道を決めるんだけど
その道は成功するかしないかということは
単なる自分だけの努力でもないんだと
またいろんな要素から出来上がるものだと
それは理解してほしい
それで親に責められてやる人の場合も
もし子供が落第しちゃったら
親がまた子供のことを責めようとしちゃうんですね
それまた間違いであって
成功するかしないかということは
まあ単なる子供一人だけの努力によるものでもないんです
どうしようもない要素もそこにあるんです
例えば  10人しか入らない試験に 100人が入ったと
でも 100人も抜群に能力があるんだったら
もうしょうがないんでしょう
その場合は ですから この柔軟性も必要なんです
だから あまりエゴイストになっちゃうと
もうすぐ自分が折れてしまうんです
自分というものが そこでこの人間にそれはあるんですね
もうなんか自己というアイデンティティを作ろうと思うのはいいんだけど
すぐそのアイデンティティが固まって
もう凍り固まっちゃう
ですから 凍り固まらないように
柔軟性あるアイデンティティを作らなくちゃいけない
そうすると なかなかそんなに問題にはならないんですね
次に出てくる問題っていうのは
まあ人々っていうのはもう何かやると必ず成功する
成功してやると という気持ちもあるんですね
それまたあってもなくてはならないし
あっては危ないことなんです
それ理解してほしい 何か自分でやるならば
それは成功しなきゃ意味がないでしょうし
失敗するために何かやることは意味がないし
だからといって必ずしも成功してやるぞというふうにきつく思っちゃったら
もう大変な問題が起こっちゃうんです
なぜならば 我々は何かすると成功するかしないかということは
またいろんな原因要素で決められるものですから
このいろんなこの塾とか
そういうところの教えてる先生たちにもある問題なんですね
自分の塾に入った自分の教室に入った生徒たちが 9
割以上希望の大学に合格しなくちゃいけないんだと言って
塾の管理というか その経営をやっている人々は先生を責めちゃうんですね
それ あんまりにもひどいんですね
その責め方っていうのは
それでみんなの頭にまくわり
なんて言いますか なりまきはちまきを巻いて
先生もなんかもう戦争やってるんですね
塾で だから先生も自分の首はかかってるし
だから気持ちよくリラックスして楽しく教えることできないし
で 生徒たちにも余計な怒り
苦しみ 競争心 もうお互いに憎み合うことしかもう何もなくなっちゃうんですね
だからあんまりも自然否定なんですね
100人教室に入ったら
100人の 90人以上希望の大学に合格するってありえない話で
そこでなんかなく中道というものを考えなくちゃいけないんですね
生徒たちとあなた方はもう思い存分頑張りなさいと
後で悔いは残らないように頑張れと
私も後でもう教え損なったという悔いがないように
とことん教えるんだと
よく教えてあげたと私も自慢できるように教えるんだと
あんた方もよく勉強したそうと自慢できるように勉強しなさいと
それで十分じゃないかと
もし希望の大学に入らなかったら
まあしょうがない 他の大学にやればいいんじゃんということで
まあ次に決めちゃえばいいと
そこは否定するんですね
塾では自然法則を 自然法則を否定するのはあんまりもひどいんです
それはもう太陽は東から昇るということを否定することと同じなんですから
私はいくら嫌だと思ったっても
太陽は東から昇るんだからしょうがないでしょうに
いくら否定したくなくても冬は寒いんだからしょうがないでしょ
そんなことは 冬を恨むんじゃなくて
なんか厚いコートでも着ればそれで問題解決するでしょうに
ですから この目的を作るのはいいんだけど
あんまりにも非合理的に自然法則を否定して目的を作ると精神的な問題が起こるんですね
ですから 人間には希望ですか
希望っていうのはなくてはならない
あったら大変危険なものなんですね
いつでもそれを覚えておいてください
それが正しい心の持ち方なんです
なくてはならないんだけど
あったらもの大変危険だと
あの人格というか 自分のアイデンティティ場合も同じなんですね
アイデンティティっていうのはなくてはならないもので
あったら大変危ないというものなんです
全部そういうふうに見てほしいんです
他の心理学の本なんか読んでみると
そうじゃなくて もう決まってるんですね
こういう生き方 こういう生き方
こういう生き方だと なんで人間の自信なくなりますかというと
あれは自信ありすぎなんですね
自信なくなるのは 自信ありすぎて
それでやろうとしたら何一つもできないんですね
例えば結婚式で挨拶するんだと
ほんの 2 3分のことなんですけど
それでいっぱい頭で妄想して妄想して
もう抜群の挨拶してやろうではないかと思って
これ  3分の挨拶には 30 分かかってるんだけど
何も喋ってないと それで心臓もドキドキするわ
汗が出るわ 膝が揺れるわ
もうひどいもんなんですよね
だからこの自信がない人々は
前もって妄想であまりにも自信がありすぎ
自分のことをあまりにも評価しすぎ
だからダメなんです だから自信が何もない人が抜群にやっちゃうんです
だからそういう人は まあどうせ私は口下手で下手だから
ろくに挨拶できないんだから
ほんの 1 分くらい何か喋って早く逃げようと
それでその人は 1 分くらい何とか何とか喋って早く逃げちゃうんですね
でも その 1 分で喋ることはぴったし
すごい綺麗な もうすごいいい言葉なんですね
例えばあまり私はもう長い時間喋れません
だからとにかくおめでとうございます
ありがとうございます
すぐ入っちゃう それでみんな大ウケなんですね
それだけのことなんです
それできないんだから
あれは自信がありすぎなんですね
会社で仕事をするために自信がないというのは
なんかものすごい奇跡的な成功を出そうと頭で妄想で思ってるんですね
だからできない まあそこそこでいいんじゃないかと思わないんですね
そこでそこそこでいいんじゃないかと思ったら
また危ないところというのは
そうするとなんか仕事あの
ろくにしないということになりますけど
ですから 自分に悔いがないようにということは大事なんですね
自分が一応 精一杯やりましたと
結果は自分だけのことじゃないんだと
もう一つ 人間問題を作るポイントがありまして
それは基準の問題というかね
どんなものにも初めからもうまあ
決めているんです 決めつける基準
これは正しくて これは間違っていると
これはもう正しいやり方だとかね
で 初めから基準を設けたっても
我々頭の中で決まっている
法則で人間には生きていられないんです
例えば学生だからもう夜 12時まで勉強して
また朝 4時に起きて勉強するべきですよとかね
そういうのを基準作るでしょ
奥様方もいろんな自分たちにいろいろ戒めを作ってるでしょうに
これこれこれやらなくちゃいけないんだと
そういうふうに自分自身でいろんな生き方やら基準やら規則やら決めて
自分の足も手も全部縛っておいて
それに沿って生活できないんです
本当は 必ずしも毎日朝 5時に起きますよと決めちゃって
本人が で 起きられないでしょうに
起きられる日もあって
起きられない日もあるんですね
それですごく悩むんです
今年はこの会社でこれぐらいのもう成績出して
これぐらい儲かりますよと
まず基準をつけちゃって
で  1年全部やって計算したところでダメだと
それで社員みんないじめちゃうんですね
だから勝手にまあいい加減基準をつけちゃったら問題なんですね
そこもあってはならぬ
あったら危ないものなんですね
なくてはならぬ あったら危ないという問題なんです
だから基準を作る時でも
まあ一定の人間性も計算して
会社でこれぐらい儲かりそうと思ったっても
今年は 1億円儲けたんだから
来年は 2億でなければいけませんと
それじゃないんです なぜ 1億円儲けたかと
その環境も理解して 来年はこういう風になるだろうということも予想して
それだったらまあこれぐらいの目的はもしかすると達成するかもしれませんと
そうでないかもしれませんし
2億円と思ったっても 4億円儲かる可能性もあるし
ですから そういうふうな
この世の中のことも計算して
人間はあくまでも人間であること
ぴったし生活 なんだかんだでもね
もうきちんとこのコンピューターみたいに動かないことを考えておかなきゃいけないんです
ですから 基準というのはまた大変な人間の問題なんです
規則を作るのは簡単だけど
そんなに守られませんね
だから人間っていうのはあまりにも自分に厳しいとかね
バカバカらしいんです
ただ自分責めるだけ 自分に頭の頭の中だけ自分に厳しいんだけど
実際には自分がいい加減に生きてるんだから
だからずっと自分比べる
自分の 1日 今日の生き方と自分の頭のあの
理想と あ 今日もダメだあと
で バッテンだと 次の日も今日もバッテン
人生はバッテンだらけなんですね
で そこだから精神的な問題になっちゃうんです
それも考えた方がいいんです
人間っていうのはワシですよと
ですから 校則 いろいろ学校で校則を決めるでしょうに
それによって悪い結果が出ていくし
会社はそれなりにいろんな規則を作って
それによって悪い結果が出ていけちゃうし
そこで我々に必要なのは
このそういう何かに束縛されている生き方ではないんです
いろんな規則に いろんな基準に
いろんな目的に もういわゆるいろいろ数字に束縛されて
それを狙っても 必死になって自分を捨てて行動する人生じゃないんです
例えば子供をとにかくいい大学に入れてやるんだと思って
お母さんが自分勝手に何かね
目的決めちゃって それで全部見えなくなっちゃうんですね
鬼になってしまっちゃうし
そういう人生っていうのは人生じゃないんです
私の子はもう天才にしてやるぞと思っちゃったら
それで子供から見れば
ただの自分をいじめている鬼ババしか何もないんですね
ですから それはお母さんだけではなくて
お父さんも同じことで
会社も同じことで 社会も学校もみんなそういうふうに何か基準をつけちゃったら
もうすぐこの人々が忘れるのは
自分も他人も人間であること
生き物であること すごいデリケートで精神を持ってるっていうことを忘れちゃうんです
決めたんだからやりなさいと
そればっかりなんですね
ですから 我々に必要なのは
いくら日本でそれは人気あってもなくても
私には関係ないんだけど
そういうくだらない非現実的な基準を作らないで
非現実的な目的を作らないで
目的はなくてはならないものなんですが
あったら危険なものでもということも理解して
ある この自由な心 ものすごい楽しみを味わう心
毎日楽しみ 生きる喜びを味わう心なんですね
仕事をして それによって喜びを味わう
勉強して それによって喜びを味わう
子育てをして それによってまあ生きててよかったという喜びを味わう人生なんですね
基準に縛られたら それはできなくなっちゃうんです
基準というか そういう妄想概念みたいな何かに捕まったらできなくなっちゃうんです
だからガリガリの人生じゃないんですよね
自由に思い存分頑張ろうではないかと
例えば目的あったらそれこそストレスでしょうに
すごい緊張するでしょうに
人がストレス溜まったら
緊張したら仕事できますかね
例えば ずっとバイオリンの練習した人がいるとします
そしてその人は基準を作っちゃう
私は最高の演奏をするんだと
そこで最高の演奏のことを頭に浮かんじゃって
イメージ イメージがあったりして
本当の発表会であまりにも緊張して
筋肉が固まっちゃって何もできなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 発表会に行ったっても
自分の家で練習したことと同じく
なんかリラックスして楽しく演奏してやると
だから演奏発表会に行く前にも
なんのことなく ニコニコニコとみんなと遊びながらいて
まあ発表 自分の順番が来たらちゃんと発表して
それでまたすごい楽しく終わる状態
この全くストレスないリラックスした状態が必要なんです
それを作るのはそんなに難しいことじゃないんです
余計な見栄を捨てればね
余計なこの目的 あんまりにも欲張って作る目的なんか
捨てればいいんですね
楽しもうではないか 味わおうではないか
そうすると何でも楽しいんです
山登りも もう海を渡ることも
もう何でも楽しいんです
仕事をすることでも楽しいし
リラックスしているし
その人を持ってる最高の結果を出しちゃうし
はい  で まだたくさんありますけど
まあそれからいろいろこの鈴木先生がこのいろんなこの実例とか何とかまとめてありますから
そこら辺ちょっと話してみます
こちらに 1つあって このまあ
このどなたかと まあ一応わからないように書いているんですけど
ある方がなんかこの 自分の思い通りに人が頼んだことをやってくれないと
で 人を他人がなんで人によく迷惑をかけているんだということを
その問題として考えているんですね
大体どなたにでもあることで
まあよくあることなんですけど
バスに乗る時でも あの乗ってからまた財布を開けて
お金入れて また出して
また間違ってとかね ずっとまた並んでるんですね
で もうなかなかもうバスに乗れないとかね
結構いら立ちますよ その時も
あの 随分まあ 駅でも同じことなんですね
カウンターで切符買ってみてください
一人に取る時間というと
ぶん殴りたくなるんですよ
なんでこんなに人が まず日本 JR だからいっぱい人が切符買ったりするでしょうし
そこで高い値段の切符だったらね
人を直接買わなくちゃいけないでしょうね
それは向こう側が遅いにも関わらず
こちら側もまたこれは何ですか？これはどうですか
ああですか こうですかと
また聞いたり聞いたり
聞いたり 聞いたり 一人にまあ 3分 4分ぐらいかかっちゃうんですね
で 私もそういう経験がありますけど
すぐ新幹線に乗りたくて
あの まあ時間計算して行ったんだけど
ここで4人並んでいたんです
ああ 4人だったら大丈夫だと
もう大丈夫ではなかったんです
前の人はもうなんか全て電車の歴史まで聞いてるんですか？と思ったんだけどね
だからそういうことは世の中でよくあることなんですね
こちらでも書いてましたけど
なんかまあなんか椅子カート直すに行ったら
決して自分の注文通りにやってくれないんだと
ああだこうだとかね もうタバコ吸う人をね
まあタバコを自分で吸うんで
他人にどれぐらい迷惑をかけているんですか？とかね
全然気にしないんだけど
なんで人が人々がそういう風に迷惑をかけているんですか？それで苛立ちをするんだと
で まあそういう系統には私もよく毎日のように会ってますけどね
じゃあどうすればいいんですかね
簡単なお話なのでぶん殴ってください
この野郎と早くしなさい
どうすればいいんですかね
その場合は だから私はぶん殴ってくださいっていうこと
この単なるまあまあ面白い話ではなくて
それはこの迷惑をかけられている
という思う人の気持ちなんですね
ぶん殴りたくなるの 早くしろと
でもそれは答えにならないでしょ
普通だったら我々もどれぐらい人をぶっ殴ったらいいんですかね
その場合 自分の子供をぶん殴らなくちゃいけない
小さな子供に早く準備しろと言ってみてください
学校に遅くなりますよと
やってくれないでしょ
またあくびをしながらあっち行ったりこっち行ったり
ご飯も早く食べないし
お母さんがいら立ってるんですね
そんなのんびりやっちゃったら
もうもう遅刻するんだよと
それでやっと行ったら
また何かカバン忘れるわ
何か弁当忘れるわ また追いかけてきて
それあげなくちゃいけないしね
ですから  そういうこと
世の中にごく普通にあることなんですね
そこで問題は もしいら立ちしたならば
問題は私は私のことしか考えてないんですね
自分のために世の中が回ってくれということなんですね
私は忙しいんだから あなた方忙しくしなさいと
それで他人から見れば
あんた勝手に私は関係ないんですよという状態なんですね
私には関係ないんだと
だから  JR のあの駅で切符売ってる人の方
私はのんびりしてきてるんで
仕事してるんであってね
あなた方はどんな忙しいの関係ないんだと
そういう状態なんです
で それ理解しておけばいいんですね
ですから そこで見られるのは
自分が自分勝手にいろんなことを考えていることなんですね
早く何とかやりたいとかね
で 例えば店にあの自分のズボンとかなんとか
もう直しに頼んだところで
自分の希望通りにやってくれなかったならば
もう何か問題あるんで
自分言った言い方が まあ一つ
これ言っちゃいけないんだけど
まあなんかみんな言い過ぎなんですね
そこで日本語の問題があって
たくさん言葉を使うんですね
結局何も言ってないんです
私のやり方聞かない すぐ一言葉言うと
あ この人こういうこと言いたがってるんだ
すぐもう決まって それから聞かない
他のことやってるんですね
だから全部聞くと 一体全体あんた何を言いたいんですか？と聞きたくなっちゃうんです
だから このもうちょっと我々の日本語をもうちょっとしっかり直した方がいいんです
しっかりと喋った方がいいんですね
それは自分たちがしっかり考えてないんだからなんですね
ですから まあスカートでもいい
ズボンでもいいし 直してほしい場合は
私はこういう風な形に
こんな感じで こういう風になってほしいんですと
どうすればいいでしょうかと
お願いしますと と言った方がいいし
きちんと あるいは自分はわからないんだったら
私はわかりませんだからあなたはプロだから
とにかくかっこよく見せるように作ってください
お願いしますと人に頼むか
そういう風にカッコよくしてください
人に頼んだら その人がすごくあっ
私は認めてくれたんだと
だからその人を驚くようなことをしなくちゃいけないと
その人は責任取っちゃうんです
で いい結果になる あるいは自分できちんと決めて
こういうこういうことですと
だから駅の場合は同じことなんですね
このこの時間で この電車にこれ切符くださいと
ここまでと サッと言ったら
向こうも何のこともささ
その駅の前のコンピューターですから
押してはいどうぞで出してくれるんですね
だからきちんと頭をしっかりしてないんですね
1万6800 800円だったら
もうそれそれなりにお金持っていって
そうすると早いんですね
だから問題はほとんど自分の側にあるんですね
私はバスに乗る時はだいたい 200円はきちんと最初から用意しているんです
あるいは 200 200円
180円とかね ですからね
何のことなく用意していて
だから前のおばあちゃん
おばあちゃんたち だいたいバスに乗るのはね
おばあちゃん おじいちゃんたちだから
どうせ遅いんですけどね
それは別に それで私はもう2 3 秒で仕事終わって
さっと中に入っちゃうんです
で それもそれは一つで
それでこの他人の立場からまたもう一つ見る方法があるんですね
やっぱりそのその人々のスピードというものがあるんだからね
例えばおばあちゃんが切符買う場合はね
まあこれでいいでしょうかね
何線でしょうか 何番ですかとかね
聞くと ああ やっぱりおばあちゃんだからね
しっかり聞いてるんだとかね
可愛く見たらどうですかね
やっぱりおじいちゃんだから足が弱いんだからね
ここら辺はちょっとまあ遅いでしょ
もうちょっと場所を空けてあげましょうとかね
そういう風に他人のことを優しく見ると
で まあタバコを吸う場合も同じことな
タバコを吸う人はほとんどまあ他人の迷惑は考えない時はありますからね
ほとんどの人々がね でも本当に紳士たちもいますよ
タバコを吸う男性の場合は
まあ女性の場合は紳士は一人もいませんだから女性だからね
タバコを吸う場合は誰でも行儀が悪いんですけどね
であれ精神的に弱いんだからね
タバコ吸ってるし でも昨日僕は行ってみたんだけど
この私もこの一番乗り降りるのが早いところに大体行くんですね
早く乗って早く降りて早く出かけたいんだから
なんか何か運が悪くわからないんだけど
そういう場所はいつでも喫煙の場所なんです
だからそれはしょうがないんです
私もタバコの煙はすごく体に何かすごい気持ち悪くなるんですね
それで昨日見たんだけど
あるしっかりした中年の男性でしたけど
で 早く来ていて もう前の方にいて
タバコ吸いたかったんですね
そこでタバコを吸うところは何か白い線で枠を決めてあったんですね
あれが枠のところに来て
タバコを取って 枠をちゃんと見て
きちんと枠の中に枠の中に入って
灰皿の前でちゃんと立って
タバコを取って吸い始めたんです
あれ見たら僕はすごい喜びを感じたんですね
やっぱりさすが紳士だと
ちゃんと枠を見て きちんと枠の中にこうやって入る
だから その人の煙は私の鼻に入っても
全然嫌な気持ちはしなかったんですね
やっぱり他人に迷惑をかけないようにすごい気をつけているんだと
そういうことを見ると
本当に素晴らしい人だと
そのような人にはタバコを吸わせてあげたくなるんです
だから自分が吸いたいし
だからといって他人にこれを自分のことだから
他人には迷惑かけなくて
ちゃんと行儀よくやろうと
そこでもっと若いだらしのない人もいたんですね
あの人はわざと枠の外からいて
この灰皿とすごい遠いんですね
で 私が立っているところでタバコ吸ってるんですね
あの人は足で蹴っ飛ばしたくなったんだけどね
吸いたくなるんだったらちゃんと行儀よくやりなさいと
だからその性格の悪さもありますけど
かえって私はその時も怒らなかったんで
怒ったら私が損するんだから
タバコの煙を吸うだけじゃなくて
精神的に怒って損までする必要ないでしょうね
私は考えます  みんなそれなりに考えて行動するんだからね
別に自分のことしか考えられないし
その人の立場から見ると
まあまあそれぐらいのところでいいんじゃないかとね
それで本人の肺がそこも落ちるんだけど
見ていたら まあ本人もある時間経つと灰皿まで行って
灰を落としてまた戻るんで
その前は全部落ちているんだけどね
でも本人はしっかりやってるつもりなんですね
あのだらしのない若い男性にしたっても
ですから それを理解すると
別にまあ何のことなくなっちゃうんです
ですから そういう他人が
迷惑かけてるんだと人に文句言うんじゃなくて
理解しておけばそういう問題は解決します
で みんなそれなりにもうやってるんだからね
すごい荷物持って 例えばおばあちゃんが電車に乗ろうと思っちゃうと
満員電車にね かなり迷惑なんですけど
そのおばあちゃんの立場から考えちゃうと
まあなんとか許してあげようという気持ちは生まれてくるんですね
もう一つ この 上司は尊敬できませんと
仕事を嫌になって ノイローゼになってしまったんだというふうな話があって
で 今 離婚希望中なんとか中で
まあ子供がいて まあいろいろトラブル書いてるんだけどね
まあ仕事が変わって 仕事はできなくて
上司は嫌いになって 離婚にもなって
あとはああだこうだとか
子供の問題でも悩んでるんだと
で まあそれでキツいなことで言うのは
あんた下手ですよってことしか言えないんだけどね
で 仕事を変わっただけで上司のことを嫌いになるということは
自分には仕事にすべて自信がないということなんですね
どこかで怠けがあるんですね
慣れてる仕事だけやりたいんだと
それ慣れてる仕事をやっちゃうと自分で誤解するんで
仕事上手だと 毎日同じことをやってるんだから
もうどうせできるでしょうに
それで私はすごい仕事をバリバリやってるのに上手だと
だから人生は知ってるんだと
世の中知ってる ものすごい良くないんですね
そうじゃないんですね
本当に上手かないかっていうのは
慣れてない仕事に回された時にわかるんですね
ですから そういう方々は
これは自分の能力の試し試しだと
というふうに思わなくちゃいけないんですね
仕事は上手にできたくてもできなくても
それは構いません 新しいことに変えちゃったら
まあこれ私の能力の試しだと
で やってみたところで
新しい経験 新しい刺激
新しい人生観が生まれてくるんです
離婚になっても別に構いません
それから私は新しい人生をやらなくちゃいけないんだと
これからまた新しい刺激あるでしょうに
でも 離婚を嫌がる人は
やっぱり決まってるパターンで
毎日マンネリで生きたいんですね
あんなものはもうものすごい
もう暗くて情けないと思いますよ
毎日決まってる時間で起きて
決まってる食べ物を食べて
決まってる場所に行って
決まってる仕事をして
決まってる時間で時間で帰って
決まってる時間で寝て
決まってる どこまで決まってるんですかね
だから決まりないのは人生なんですね
朝起きてみたら大雪で仕事に行けないんだと
電車が止まってるんだ
だから決まってる人々
ものすごく苦しみ味わっちゃうんですね
人生決まってない人は
今日は会社にも行けないし
電車は止まってるし じゃあ雪だるまでもして遊ぼうという風になるだけなんですね
ですから 仕事を変わることは決して悪いことじゃないんです
お子さんが離婚しようと言ったら
もうすごく喜んで 待っていました
という感じで もうやった方がいいんです
決まってない方がいいんです
人生っていうのは やはり脳細胞に頭にすごい刺激なんか必要なんですね
だからその問題のある方々はそういうふうに考えた方がいいと思います
それで学校に子供が行ってくれませんで
どうしたら行かすことができますかと
それは僕は何回もそのことを言っていたんだからね
学校に子供が行かないんだったら
どうして行かせるかと
簡単に答えはね 子供に言ってください
行かなくてもいいと それだけ
行かなくてもいいですよ
勉強しなくても そのまんまで
で  1 日はそうやって行かせないようにする
2 日目からは じゃあ一緒に学校にどうせ行かないんだからね
一緒に家のいろんなことをやりましょうと
すごい優しく一言も言わないでね
家の手伝いはもう片っ端からやってもらう
自分が料理するときは
じゃああんたもニンジン皮むきなさいと
こういう風に切りなさいと
もうじゃあ掃除しましょう
あんたこれやりなさい
これなさい この窓を拭きなさい
私はお母さんがこれやりますからとかね
買い物に行く時も引っ張っていくとかね
荷物を持たせるとか 庭の掃除やらせるとかね
ああだこうだとか ものすごい忙しくしておけば
これ嫌ですよと 子供はもうまだ学校に行く可能性もあるし
で 全く聞かないとやる場合もあるんですね
学校に行かなくてもいいと
それは親を心配させたいんですね
子供は 子供に乗らなきゃいいんです
心配しないんだと そうすると子供は心配する
自分のことを それは一つのやり方
もう一つは 子供は本当に学校に行きたいんだけど
他の問題あるかもしれませんし
学校の問題とかね で 学校で仲うまくいかない場合は
それは子供だけの問題で
それはもう子供をちょっといじめてあげればいいんですね
あんたなんでもう間抜けないんで
なんで弱いんですかとね
ぶん殴ったらもう殴り返せと
もう何か悪いこと言っちゃったら言い返せばいいでしょうにと
あんた方同じ年同士で勝手にやりなさいと
そういうふうに言ってあげればいいし
先生なんかの態度悪いんだったらね
それはそれなりにところに行って喋るしか方法ないんですけどね
ですから そこで原因を探す
探して何とかしてあげることなんですね
とにかく子供たちは自分を友達にしてないんですね
子供たちが学校に行きようになってくると
もう親をやめた方がいいんです
だからあくまでも親でやっちゃうと
子供とはものすごい隔たりが生まれるんですね
すっごく 学校行き始めたら
もう一人前で まあ友達みたいに
まあなんとなくどうですかとかね
話したり見て話したりするんです
子供たちが 親が友達だと思って
今日はこういうことになったよ
すぐ親が親になっちゃうんですね
これはいけませんよと説教するんですね
だから悪いことじゃあ
あまり悪いことを子供はしませんだけど
この説教することをやめて
そうそう あんたよくバカなことをやるなとか
なんとか 何のこともなく言って友達になれることができれば
問題はないんですけどね
ですから そういう方法でそういうのは解決しますね
子供たちと友達になること
あまり学校に行きなさい
行きなさいと言わないこと
子供っていうのは親の言うことに反対をやりたがるんだから
学校に行くなと言った方がいいんです
行くなと言うんだから行くんですから
それほどの問題はないんです
またこちらたくさんありますけど
またあのうんと一人がこの親の顔を見ると
ものすごく憎しみが出てくるんだと
小さい時からこのいつもこの叱られてからだと思いますが
どうしても正直になれませんと
まあそれは大変大胆で大きな問題なんですね
小さい時から自分が親にいじめられたんで
厳しく育てられた それでもう親のことをものすごく嫌で嫌いという状態なんですね
どうしたらいいんです
その場合は で 問題はこういうことなんですね
答えは その人 すっごい甘えてるんで
親に 両親に いまだに甘えてほしいと
情けないんです だから私の答えはすぐ
親から離れようと 親の顔を見るのも嫌だったら
親の顔を見ないことなんですね
親といるとすぐケンカになるんだったら
もう二度と親に会わないようと思って家を出ることは一番正しい
もうお釈迦様がおっしゃったような同じ答えなんです
でも その人の限って親離れできないでしょ？だから正直じゃないんですね
親に 依存したがる 親はそれを嫌がる
そういうだけなんですね
親から見れば独立するのは当たり前だから
小さい時から厳しく育てるんです
その人は親に依存したがっちゃうんですね
だから結果どうでも過去はどうでもいいんです
そういう人々が 親と喧嘩する人々
親と一緒にいると素直にならない人々は
覚悟を決めてすぐ家を出ることなんです
電話一本も親にかけないこと
それで自分でしっかりと一人で生きることできたところで
親の感謝はわかってくるんです
それで何のことなく 素直にまあ親とまた話し合ったり
仲良くしたり お正月なんかに一緒にいて
お雑煮とか食べたりすることできるようになるんです
ですから そういう人々はすぐ親を離れることはもう絶対的な行動なんですね
僕はこの答えてはいけないという質問に
まあ一応印を入れておいたんだけど
答えてはいけない 一つ問題があって
それを言います 人が触ったものに触れるのさえ嫌い
嫌いで いつも消毒剤 消毒薬ですか
持っていますと 手すりに捕まることもできませんと
それぐらいこの精神的な問題があったりとかね
人が触ったものはもう触れた
もう消毒剤持っていると言ってるんだからね
そういう場合は 私はこれは私は答えてはいけないというように印を入れておいたんだけどね
そういう人はやっぱりこの仏教の立場から見れば
先生にお医者さんに会った方がいいぐらいのひどい病気なんですね
でも治そうと思ったらね
治せますけどね 僕らにも
そういう人に限ってものすごい不潔なんですね
決して清潔な人じゃないんです
だからそれをその人にね
教えてあげればね いわゆる周りの人々はあんた汚いんだからあっち行きなさいとね
追い出せば まあそれでも
だからもうすごい あの
またそこはシグムンドフロイトの本の中でも同じ
いろいろ問題とかね ありましたけどね
そこで特殊ですから 仏教ではまあ答えてはいけないと決めたんだけどね
そういうケースは決して稀な珍しいケースではなくて
昔の心理学のテキストでもよく出てくるんです
でもあんまり清潔感というのはものすごい病気なんですね
この世の中でそんな清潔とかね
ありえないんです 何が不潔ですかね？何が汚いんですかね
ただの世界でしょうし
で そういう人々が自分の体を見た方がいいんです
私はもし心理精神科の先生だったら
お医者さんだったらやらせる人仕事あるんです
その人の自分のうんこを体中もう塗らしてあげるんです
あなたのものだから最高に綺麗ですよ
1日やらせちゃったら
もうそれからそんなもう治ります
で それぐらい体の中からも汚いんだから
まあいい加減にしろと
で そこにあれもすごい高慢ですか
それで仏教の世界に入っちゃうと
自分が綺麗だと 自分が偉いんだ
自分が優れているんだと
人は汚いんだと というもう人間にあってはならない
ひどい この人間性を失っているんですね
だから本人が清潔感だと勘違いしているんですが
本人には人間としても立場がないというかね
すごい醜い考え方を持ってるんですね
人々は汚いんだ 不潔だと
だからそこはまあ私に 1発でこういうことというふうに答えられませんだけど
もし小さい時から何か頭に引っかかっちゃって
そこでそういう感じが生まれちゃったら
まあそれなりの医者が面倒を見なくちゃいけないんだけど
一応自分の体見ればね
もう一つなんですけど
自分で食べるものはね
いっぱい消毒剤や何でも使ってもいいんだけど
もう口に入れて食べて
また皿に入れてみてください
皿に入れて食べなさいと
一旦食べて口の中に入れて噛んで
それからまた出すと 出して
また箸で持って食べてみてくださいと
一回やらせたらもう不潔感消えちゃう
清潔感消えると思いますね
だからこの そういうのはまあまあ一応置きましょう
僕は もう一つ面白いことがあって
自分の夫がいつでもマイナス思考で大変神経質みたいですね
新聞の勧誘が来れば まあドア開いたら
そんな人がもううち入ったら来たらどうするんですか？とか本気で心配したりするんだそうで
まあ台風が来たら家が壊れると思って
いろんな救命道具とか用意しているとかね
で まあ奥さんから見れば
自分の夫がそういうものすごい心配性ということなんですね
いつでも台風が来たら屋根が壊れたらどうしようと
救命道具は全部揃っていると
そういうふうな このあまりにも心配していると
もうそれはどうやって直せればいいってことなんですけども
僕はつの方法を考えたんですね
一つは奥さんも同じく心配性になることなんです
だから だからこれもこちらと同じやり方で僕は仰ってるんです
この例えばこの旦那さんがこの新聞売る人がピンポン鳴らしたら
奥さんが何のことなくドア開けてなんて喋っちゃうでしょ
男はそんな人 うちのうちにいきなり入ってしまったらどうするんですか？とか
もしかして泥棒ではないかとか言うかもしれません
それは心配性でしょうね
あまりにも で それでは生きていられませんし
それで奥さんが奥さんの立場でものすごい抜群に心配性になってあげると
例えば旦那さんが何かもう道具とか
まあ包丁とかいろいろ持つでしょうね
あんたそれ触ったら怪我したらどうするんですか？とかね
お風呂に入るときも気をつけなさい
もし溺れちゃって死んじゃったらどうするんですか？って
で 大体タオルなんかはね
使ってそのまま放り出しちゃうで
これもしこれに細菌なんか入ったらどうするんですかね
もうちゃんと丁寧に畳んでおきなさいとかね
1週間ぐらいやってみれば
あれ直ります 片っ端から自分がもう何から何までもう危険性を教えてあげると
それでまあもういい加減にしましょうと本人もなっちゃうんですね
そこでなせならば本人が逆に考えちゃうんで
もうタオルぐらいそんな放り出したっても大したことないんだと
それまあ洗濯すれば綺麗になるんじゃないかと思っちゃうでしょうね
包丁を触った途端 お母さん
奥さんがすっごく驚いちゃって
もうもうキャーと泣いて
これ怪我したらあんたどうしますか？言っちゃうと
旦那の心の中でそんな怪我するわけないでしょという気持ちが生まれるでしょ
そうすると自分ももう
もう台風が来ても まあそんな必ず家が壊れるわけじゃないと
と自分にその論理性が生まれてくるんです
ですから このいい方法っていうのは
奥さんが旦那さん負けるぐらい心配性になることなんですね
それで奥さんにとってはすごいすごい面白いんです
自分でも本当はそうじゃないんだから
そういうわざとやるとすごい面白いんです
もし旦那さんがタバコを吸うだろうと思いますけど
タバコを吸うたび 「あんた
家が火事になったらどうするんですか？[笑い] ちゃんと気をつけてください」と 「
ちゃんと水のバケツをそばに置いときなさいよ」と
[笑い] で 自分で入れて置いてあげるとかね
タオル一つ濡らして 「
これ とにかくそれ持ちなさい」と
で もう一週間も経たないうちに
まあお釈迦様のスピードですから
一日で治ります そんなことは